seis meses después de este apretón de
manos la relación entre París y Berlín
extensa ambas partes están separadas en
muchos temas en materia de energía las
opiniones están divididas entre ambos
países Berlín se opone a la limitación
del precio del gas en Europa algo que
defiende París Alemania también quiere
que Francia autorice un nuevo gasoducto
para transportar gases de España algo a
lo que Francia se niega Francia al igual
que varios de sus socios europeos
también se molestó Por una medida
anunciada prolap scholls un llamado
escudo defensivo de 200 mil millones de
euros sobre los precios de la energía
para ayudar a los hogares alemanes plan
que París denunció agregando falta de
consulta y solidaridad los temas de
defensa también son objeto de debate con
un presupuesto de 100.000 millones de
euros Alemania Ahora parece querer hacer
las cosas por su cuenta favoreciendo la
compra de materiales estadounidense en
detrimento de la industria europea
además ha lanzado un proyecto de defensa
antiaérea con Estados Unidos Israel y
otros 14 países europeos un proyecto del
que Francia ha rechazado a formar parte